hey guys how's it going so today we're
going to talk about some of my favorite
ios 10 features and if you guys haven't
updated yet that's okay it's not going
anywhere feel free to do so or just
don't if you don't like change so one of
the first features for me that's
apparently noticeable is when you raise
your phone it now automatically will
wake up whereas before you'd have to
push the side of the phone or push the
home screen button to wake your phone
but now it's you pick it up and it's
like hey i'm ready to do whatever task
it is that you want to be done so i'm
going to be showing you guys a
combination of things on my phone and a
combination of things on apple's website
because they have it laid out better and
some of my notifications
are just full of nonsense so it'll be
easier to show you guys things here as
opposed to my phone so you can use 3d
touch in things like the calendar
weather in stocks so you can get more
information about them so if you don't
have a 3d touch-enabled phone you won't
be able to use these features you're
really not missing out on that much but
once you do get used to doing the force
touch you can get pretty used to it so
here's one of the notifications so if i
force touch it i can like or retweet it
so i'm gonna like it and then it clears
that from your notification list the
apple control center is all new the
first thing you'll notice is they change
these top colors the wi-fi and the
bluetooth so they're now colored i kind
of i don't know i'm not a huge fan of
the colors i kind of liked the grayscale
look but it does sort of fit the whole
ios 10 theme from here you have access
to your flashlight
like always
this will take you quickly to your timer
this will take you quickly to your
calculator
and it'll take you to your camera
you can also go to airplay or your
airdrop you can also change your night
shift but if you swipe over you'll have
access to your apple music or you can
play
system capture
that's what i'm doing right now i'm
capturing the system so but from over
here you can play music from spotify or
apple music i'm still real into spotify
although they did redo apple music so
we'll take a look at that in a little
bit when you swipe over this is all new
home kit is one of the biggest
integrations in ios 10 and i'm such a
huge fan of smart home devices so with
this anything that has a smart home logo
you'll see right there this little guy
right here you'll be able to connect
using ios 10 your iphone and control it
so i'm a huge hue light fan hence pretty
much my entire house is decked out in
view lights i did a video on that before
if you want to check those out and see
what those are all about so here i can
turn off lights
in my office
just by tapping see so here's all the
lights that i have so if you have to go
through and add those into any sort of
actual list but here i'll show you the
hue app pretty much the most incredible
thing ever so i can turn off all the
office lights
i can change the colors
god it's just the best thing ever
and it took me a while to set up all the
lights into different categories so i'm
gonna kind of have to go back and do
that in the home kit but homekit is
going to be incredible it's definitely
the future of
home connecting because i can also use
siri to interact with the lights i have
yet to set that up either so i've got
some setting up to do next up i want to
talk about imessage because i think i
spend pretty much most of my time in
imessage so with imessage one of the
things that if you have an apple watch
this is extremely familiar to you they
have all sorts of things that you can do
that you could do on the apple watch you
can add the
okay that was a kiss
i'm giving my sister i'm sending my
sister kisses she's probably like get
out of here you creep so you can doodle
just like you did
on the apple watch
with all sorts of colors
and you can send
so with digital touch you can sketch tap
fireball kiss heartbeat and heartbreak
tap and hold with two fingers okay let's
let's let's send jenna fireball
like this is so
beyond pointless it's unbelievable but
you better believe i'm still gonna do it
anyway hey sending jenna harpy cool i'm
sure she's really
excited about it it's under a heartbreak
it's so silly
what's this video do
oh
i can draw before or during recording
okay so i'm recording a video and i'm
gonna draw on myself this is cool this
is cool this is something really
innovating right here this is actually
this is the first time i'm doing this
video and i'm going to draw on myself
i'm drawing on myself this this is cool
this is i don't even know
this is right here right now i'm doing
this
extremely
silly
i'm into that
stickers stickers are basically
uh
oh jenna's typing she's typing what is
she gonna say how do i make the
fireworks tell me
okay jenna
i will tell you so you hold down here
and you click on screen
and from here you can scroll over
you've got balloons confetti you've got
the lasers
and the fireworks you've also got
what is this oh shooting star
but jenna wants fireworks so we're gonna
send her fireworks
so that will show up as an animation
inside of your imessage screen
did you
like them you can also slam text
and i'll do a little thing like that
you want a gentle tap
gentle
it's so silly one of the coolest things
is the invisible ink i'm not sure if
it's cool or
what it'll be used for
but
you can
tell secrets
in the invisible ink
and somebody will have to swipe their
finger over it to be able to reveal what
it is this also will work in photos so
i'm going to send down a picture of
maddie and i'm going to send it in
invisible ink so when you brush your
little finger over it it appears just
like magic just like magic so we have
slam we have loud we have gentle
invisible ink so those are our little
effects that we have i'm sure in the
future apple will either have them
available to be purchased to have some
add-ons which is quite brilliant same
with screen effects but i have a feeling
this will also potentially be something
that third-party developers are able to
make such as the stickers so there's a
sticker store so you can purchase
stickers this is one of the
little vintage stickers this is the
nintendo super mario run this one's
pretty awesome there's some delicious
little snacks i've got some eggs and
some just just a lot of really great
things i'm gonna send jenna the eggs and
listen to music to share i haven't
listened to any music yet so let's
listen to something let's listen to some
mike posner
um this is
one of my favorites
it's just the intro to his album
so now that i listen to that
[Music]
i'm gonna send it to her
and she can also listen to it so that's
kind of cool to be able to quickly share
music and especially having it
integrated into ios and imessage to be
able to share things like that so this
is sort of going to be the future of app
development it's going to be all kind of
these mini apps that will be integrated
into imessage
i also like because i'm a huge fan of
being able to search for things so if i
search for chicken
the emojis will pop up sad
i can just send those instead so if you
have your rotation orientation off and
you flip your phone over in imessage
you're able to
live
right so
i'm gonna type jenna
hey
pig
hit done
hit send so on her screen she sees me
write it
also silly
but cute
right so this is something that i'm kind
of excited about as you guys see here
apple pay on the web if you have your
touch id set up and your apple pay set
up on your phone you can just check out
with the press of a button new in photos
is photo memories and this is pretty
neat because i love using facebook and
timehop and all of these apps that will
allow me to go back in time and see the
things that i've posted on the web which
i still 100 will use because i do not
store all of my photos on my camera roll
but this is neat because i can see the
best of the last five months or three
months in 2016. so it looks like we have
e3
and all of our travels in europe for my
friend's wedding the last three months
so you can see groups and groups of
people so let's just see me oh look at
the fun that we're having together
all of the fun
may 6
2016 went to dinner had a lovely time
look at the great time that we had in
santa monica
look at the great time that i had at the
indy 500
yes
i had a lovely time
went to the trampoline park
had a lovely time
trying to think if there's anything else
that i've been really super into i think
those are pretty much the main
highlights of the things that i've
really
definitely liked the first day that i
used it it did feel just different
clearly that's something i think that
everyone is probably going through when
they first pick it up do i like this do
i not like it
i it only took me like two days and i'm
kind of really into it now a lot of the
silly features that i mentioned that i
thought were kind of childish clearly
they are childish someone brought up the
fact that they're like well you're an
adult that plays with lego and plays
video games so i don't think you have
any right to talk about childish
which point is uh definitely taken
points taken i've heard it for the most
part i think it is a pretty solid update
they do have a lot of new features i'm
so excited to try out more of the home
kit features and find different things
that i'll be able to use with that the
imessage features are cute there's going
to be so many different apps and
stickers and fun things that will come
out that you guys will be able to use
with that so i'm pretty excited about it
also a side note because i've been
making so many iphone videos some people
who are new here think that i work for
apple i i don't i don't i do not so i
just wanted to put that out there make
sure that y'all are well aware that
that's not the case never has
probably won't ever will but
i can always cross my fingers
be sure to subscribe for more fun videos
and to see all the rest of the iphone 7
adventures and if you guys like this
video you know what to do hit that
thumbs up button i'll see you later bye
[Music]